[Müzik]
nasılsınız müthiş Bence buradan gördüğüm
şey müthiş Evet Deniz ben ressam
müzisyen birisiyim ve 7 yıldır sanırım
müziği anlamak ve anlamaya çalışıyorum
dinlemeyi öğreniyorum
öyle nevait arkadaşlarım Bugün bana
sahnede destek oluyorlar
Umarım beğenirsiniz Çok teşekkür ederim
şimdiden
[Alkış]
Cehennemin dibine doğru sürükleniyorum
[Müzik]
kendini kandırma
uzaklara baktıkça
gerçeğin uğrunda bıraktım kendime
uçurumdan aşağıya
[Müzik]
düştükçe
görüyorum herkes benimle
birlikte düşünüyor
[Müzik]
sürükleniyorum
Cehennemin dibine doğru sürükleniyorum
Kaçış Yolumuz yok
yok Kaçış yolla
kaçış yolu
[Müzik]
Çok teşekkürler
Biraz üzücü bir şarkı
[Müzik]
çok düşündüm
Nereye gitsem
ne dinlesem bana seni
hatırlattın yine
ne kadar içsem
de hep
sizi bırakmıyor peşimi
yer etmiş kalbimde
nasıl Des
Em
ne der
değişik işte
söylediler bize
nasıl Des
em
neye dönüşsem
değişmeyecek işte
söylediler bize
[Müzik]
Çok sağ olun
sıradaki şarkımız geliyor
sözlerin müthiş O yüzden seçtim
kalbinize dokunur inşallah
[Müzik]
tüm
[Alkış]
Elif yılan
[Müzik]
gezsem lütfen
Ne oldu Ne oldu
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
devamı için yol
lar mısın
[Müzik]
defoluyorlar çalıyor
[Alkış]
Sevgi
kendimizi sevelim Bence en güzel yol bu
şarkı
[Müzik]
nasıl bıraksam bana
biraz sana
Ben belki de çok
heyecanlandım Bir anda öylece ağzımdan
sözcükler dökülür verdiği yerlere ve
toparlayamadım bıraktım kendimi
kollarına
[Müzik]
o zaman anladım
Hadi götür beni gezegenine
bir resimim
senin dert benim zalime
tuhafıma nedense bu tür isterim
[Müzik]
çok rahat nasıl
duyarsam bana Biraz anlatsana
[Müzik]
çok rahat nasıl
bıraksam bana Biraz anlatsana
[Müzik]
Çok teşekkürler
Teşekkür ederim çok sağ olun
Son şarkımız
[Müzik]
denizlerin uzakta Belki de yakında soğuk
sıcak orada değil saklanmış açıkta yavaş
yavaş hareket eden bir fırtına bize
doğru
yaklaşıyor
duydukça da
batıyorum
karanlık
içimden biri bağırdı Yıldızlara fazla
yaklaşma
yalan dolan düşünceler etrafımda bir
türlü rahat yüzü vermediler bana Dünya
tersine dönmüş olsa da eğer bir dileğim
yok sevgiden başka
Durdukça daha da
batıyoruz
karanlık
içinden biri Bıdı Yıldızlara fazla
yaklaşma
duydukça
da bat
[Alkış]
ıyor
Çok teşekkür ederiz nevavit grubumuza da
çok teşekkür ediyorum arkadaşlarım
yalnız bırakmadı beni desteklediler
o zaman size iyi günler diliyorum
[Alkış]
Kendinize iyi bakın